bonsoir français merci d'être avec nous
donc demain nouvelle étape les bronches
if qui appuient cette décision cet
allègement pour vous il est légitime
vouziers les le coeur léger
il est légitime oui parce que nous avons
effectivement des clignotants qui sont
au vert comme il a été dit mais avec ce
que comme l'a dit jean françois
delfraissy une surveillance intense de
tous les cas positifs sur le territoire
qui va être conduite à partir du 14 juin
sous forme de dépistage et de séquençage
de toutes les souches que nous allons
pouvoir trouver en france
alors effectivement vous parler entre
autres de ce variant delta de sept-îles
sont vos tout de même inquiété c'est un
peu aujourd'hui la seule ombre au
tableau est ce qui peut prendre à plus
ou moins long terme le dos et en france
aussi bien sûr il ya une compétition
entre les gens qui sont vaccinées
protéger et puis les gens qui ne le sont
pas dans lequel le virus évidemment peut
rendre un cluster positif un certain
nombre de gens d'où l'exploration
absolue de tous les gens qui nous il ya
une naissance d'un nouveau variant de
nouvelles mutations et donc de la
surveillance à absolu de tous ces
personnes plus d'une centaine de quatre
variantes été détectée
par séquençage c'est bien cela ça veut
dire qu'on est en dessous de la réalité
aujourd'hui
écoutez on le saura un petit peu plus
pour l'instant nous avons un criblage
qui est fait en france autour de trois
mutations que l'on recherche qui était
présente à la fois sur le variés anglais
sur le variant sud africains brésiliens
indiens et c'est autour de ces trois
mutations cible si vous voulez que l'on
va identifier les souches et qu'on va
systématiquement les passer au peigne
craint pour voir s'ils contiennent ou
non de notre mutation qui peuvent comme
vous l'avez dit avoir une dangerosité
entre en termes de contamination et en
termes aussi de résistance à la
vaccination
c'est vrai que jean françois delfraissy
un des conseils scientifiques nous on
dit attention à la reprise de l'épidémie
à l'automne ce que vous nous dites la
mutation est ce qu'elle serait la cause
justement de cette potentielle quatrième
vague qu'on espère évidemment pas bien
effectivement oui parce que si vous avez
un cerveau ou un grand nombre de
personnes rassemblées et qui n'ont pas
été vaccinés c'est important
elles peuvent contaminer à ce moment-là
devenir un cluster se disséminer et donc
on sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui on
l'avait prévu d'ailleurs que le variant
anglais prendrait le dessus sur le
vaillant traditionnels que nous avons
est la dernière maintenant c'est la
question de savoir si d'autres variantes
peuvent se substituer aux parieurs
anglais est donc évidemment contaminer
d'autres personnes
c'est cette course là ces précautions
qu'il faut garder même s'il ya
effectivement cette libération d'une
certaine manière et cette protection
qu'il faut garder quand on est dans un
endroit confiné cesser ces mesures là
qui vont voir si on va être efficace ou
pas cet été des variants qui et c'est
bien de le rappeler sont sont toujours à
priori
poreuse aux vaccins oui tout à fait pour
l'instant nous avons d'après l'om est
après tout les études que nous avons
nous avons une de bons résultats dans
tous les cas de vaccination
donc c'est ça qui va être très important
on va pouvoir surveiller aussi les gens
par leur passeport évidemment leur
passante et ce qui permettra de mesurer
aussi tous les gens vaccinés et de
mesurer plus tard éventuellement les
anticorps qui seront contre le virus
clairement aujourd'hui l'europe est au
vert dans sa globalité alors que des
pays son sens à nouveau dans la crise
grâce à quoi on peut parler de la
vaccination uniquement où il ya d'autres
raisons
non on parle aussi de la politique de
l'état qui a fait qu à un moment donné
il a été nécessaire de vacciner de
protéger nos concitoyens en disant il
faut évidemment vous met 7 jours 10
jours chez vous il faut aussi cette
politique d'identifier toutes les
personnes que vous avez pu être en
contact dans toute cette politique là
aujourd'hui paye un peu et on en
recueille les truies maintenant comme
l'année dernière ça va être l'été qui va
être une la clé de notre réussite ou pas
si nous continuons à vacciner très
fortement cet été que nous continuons à
nous protéger dans les lieux clos et que
nous essayons d'avoir un respect un peu
des gestes barrières les uns vis-à-vis
des autres on aurait une chance que au
mois de septembre octobre quand les le
temps va se changer on puisse éviter
cette quatrième vague à mot également
sur cette annonce des manuels macro
destination des discothèques rendez vous
le 21 juin
ça inquiète le biologiste que vous êtes
c'est peut-être le dernier endroit
effectivement à haut risque certainement
oui
quoique dans les discothèques il y a
puisque j'en ai j'en ai quelques membres
de l'asean qui en sont c'est un endroit
qui peut être facilement arriver en tout
cas une aspiration de l'air très forte
qui peut être déclenché donc il ya deux
possibilités mais c'est vrai que on
attend les résultats de de tous les
concerts qui vont être mené avec 1000
personnes de voir un peu quel est l'état
de dissémination parmi des gens ils sont
ensemble
donc tous et tous ces éléments là vont
permettre de prendre certainement une
décision par le chef de l'état dans une
certaine mesure avec certainement des
jauges avec certainement des précautions
mais certainement que des discothèques
qui sont dehors pour être plus
facilement accessible qu'en sous sol
merci beaucoup françois blanchecotte
président du syndicat des biologistes
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france ce soir